so you're a billionaire and to become a
billionaire you had to be extremely
extremely paranoid much more paranoid
than the average person to achieve a
billion in fact billionaires are the
most paranoid people you'll ever meet
they kind of just sit around all day
stressing about everything why do you
think so many billionaires are into
longevity and it's no wonder why
billionaires are also obsessed with
preparing for the end of the world World
War III nuclear fallout solar flares
that destroy the electricity grip
whatever you can dream of it's not just
10 foil hat people that are prepping for
it but also the billionaires because as
a billionaire if you can easily afford
it why would you want to suffer along
with the rest of the plus when the end
times arrive so what do you do you
invest a few pennies of your net worth
into a doomsday bunker we're talking a
few hundred million doar but that is
still pennies to you and no we're not
talking about some cold Barren
uncomfortable bunker we're talking about
luxurious billionaire bunkers with all
the amenities you could dream of to keep
yourself busy as the world burns
down heck even Mark Zuckerberg the most
vanilla Tech billionaire out there even
he has hopped on the billionaire bunker
train on a secluded Ranch on the island
of kawaii in Hawaii Mark has been
organizing a massive secret construction
operation the construction site is
hidden behind 6ft walls to prevent any
passing cars from seeing inside the only
Vehicles allowed are pickup trucks
carrying a variety of materials and
hundreds of workers the entire place is
crawling with security guards 24/7 and
no one is allowed to talk about what
they're building on sites not even the
different Crews working on the site are
allowed to discuss what they're doing
with each other but that's not all
everyone who works on Zuckerberg's
secret Hawaii property is also forced to
sign a super strict non-disclosure
agreement or NDA before being allowed
inside and this isn't just some old NDA
that no one ever enforces no one guy
working on the project has already been
fired just for posting a photo on
Snapchat while he was on sites another
former employee who refused to share his
identity described the project by saying
it's like Fight Club we can't talk about
it anything posted from there they get
win of it right away obviously Mark
Zuckerberg the Undisputed king of
invading everyone else's privacy is
going to Great LS to make sure that no
pictures or details of what he's
building ever gets leaked to the public
but why it's because he's building a
massive 1400 acre self-sufficient
compound which features a
state-ofthe-art doomsday bunker you know
just in case something big Mark
Zuckerberg may be planning on his
Hawaiian estate wired reports that meta
founder is building a mega Compound on
roughly 1,400 acres of land on the
island of kawaii including an
underground bunker with a concrete
filled metal door how many Have Seen the
Last of Us in the zombie apocalypse I
mean that's the first thing that comes
to mind as the author of survival of the
richest puts it if anyone has enough
money to insulate himself from the
damage created for society it would be
Zuck that's sort of what this is he's
destroyed the government and society and
now he can go to Hawaii and build a fort
and he's not the only one almost all the
biggest billionaires are pouring an
insane amount of money into buying up
land and building high-tech impenetrable
bunkers Ben fits Mark zucker's project
alone is set to cost at least $270
million and as the world becomes more
and more chaotic as the days go on it
makes you wonder what do these
billionaires know that we don't stay
dangerous subscribe for more and this is
how to survive the apocalypse
billionaire
[Applause]
[Music]
Edition and really fast if you have
money saved up and you're anxious about
everything that's happening right now
War hyperinflation our political system
seems to be declining by the minute and
you don't want your savings to be
decimated when it all collapses then you
might want to consider picking up some
gold I've always kept a percentage of my
net worth in gold because think about it
there's a reason why every Central Bank
will happily print money and give it to
you while they secretly hoard gold
behind closed doors like Scrooge McDuck
there's a reason why China is
stockpiling gold right now and that's
why now is the time to call one of the
most trusted precious metal dealers out
there American Harford gold they'll show
you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
wealth portfolio with physical gold and
silver with the finest products of
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment American Harford go has a
five-star rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau and what's great is that
they support content like this that's
committed to bringing you the truth tell
them I sent you and they'll give you up
to $5,000 of free silver on your first
order so call them now click the link
below or call 866
671-4316 6671 4392 or text TR to 65532
again that's 8666 71439 2 or text TR to
655 532 thanks to them for sponsoring
this
video Mark Zuckerberg has been doing his
best to keep his luxury hole in the
ground as Secrets he's even spent almost
10 years buying up separate sections of
land using shell company so it wouldn't
draw too much attention but not even the
Godfather of social media can escape the
power of his own creation small details
have been slowly trickling out of the
construction site so we can get at least
a general idea of what he's building
inside we know that there would be two
football field siiz mansions in the
middle of the compound complete with
elevators offices conference rooms and
an industrial kitchen there will also be
a full-size gym sauna pool and tennis
court but those are just the icing on
the cake millions of houses around the
world have pools and Tennis Courts what
really sets this property apart is
what's going on underneath it as far as
we can tell Mark's underground bunker is
going to be absolutely insane the bunker
will be accessible from the main
Mansions via a tunnel it will be fully
equipped to sustain itself generate
energy grow food and store all sorts of
supplies it will even have its own water
tank and pump system but the shelter
isn't just being built for comfort is
also built to keep everyone else out the
shelter's door is made of a thick metal
that's filled with concrete a common
practice for bomb shelters the bunker
will also have soundproof walls and an
extensive network of security cameras
and that's about all we know and Mark
isn't the only one keeping his bunker
Ambitions under reps Frank Vander
a wellness entrepreneur with over $3
billion just bought a 2,000 acre wrench
just a little south of Mark Zero's
property for $ 51 million Peter tal
PayPal's Hideout of choice is New
Zealand where he has a 477 acre former
sheep station in the south island and as
it turns out he and Sam Alman the CEO of
open AI are actually apocalypse buddies
who agreed to lay low at te's hideout in
New Zealand once the end times begin
billionaire Max Levin said that most of
the world's richest people are all
putting money into creating an emergency
plan like these guys so now that you're
sold on creating a billionaire bunker
the next step is obviously choosing
where you want to actually build
it
[Music]
New Zealand is the dream apocalyptic
getaway for billionaires for a few
reasons it's an isolated island that is
still a Western Country it has a pro
business environment it's a safe haven
for the rich and practically speaking
it's got a lot of Clean Water
agricultural land and it's only an
overnight flight away from Los Angeles
so it's no surprise that New Zealand has
become a favorite especially among the
tech billionaires of Silicon Valley
Third question the one that made me
realize that this was more than I signed
up for they said uh Alaska or New
Zealand meaning where should they
situate their bunkers for the event Reed
Hoffman one of PayPal's other Founders
explain that saying you're buying a
house in New Zealand is kind of a wink
wink St noore kind of thing for years
New Zealand has been an apocalypse
Escape destination for America's Elite
notable home buyers include the tech
Tycoon Peter theal an outspoken
supporter of Donald Trump he's also bet
that America was not the place to be if
things collapsed so he arranged for a
New Zealand passport just in case even
Google co-founder Larry Page got
residency in New Zealand recently and
holds property there places like New
Zealand Hawaii and Alaska make for great
Hideout locations they're far away from
the big cities they've got a lot of
resources and land available to go food
and build and they're easily accessible
on short notice if things get ugly fast
but while choosing the location of your
bunker is pretty straightforward
figuring out exactly how to build it and
what you'll need can be a lot harder
which is why billionaires like you have
to turn to the professionals the
companies that build these
bunkers
step number two hire a professional
doomsday bunker building service where
there's money being spent ambitious
entrepreneurs will follow and the
underground bunker industry is no
exception see as a billionaire you don't
want to give up your luxuries even in
the end of the world you don't want to
survive only doesn't have to suffer and
live like a Savage you want your
survival shelter to live up to your
current lifestyle luckily for you there
are several companies that offer exactly
that if a nuclear conflict were to erupt
what kind of facility would protect its
occupants from a direct Atomic blast if
you ask Robert Vino the answer resides
with his California based shelter
company vivos that builds fully stocked
underground bunkers designed to
withstand massive disasters and
catastrophes this is vivos specialist in
creating High and long-term survival
shelters for members of the upper class
even though vivo's Target customers
aren't really billionaires they do offer
a great entry-level service for those
looking to explore the world of luxury
Doomsday Bunkers the company converts
missile silos Cold War storage
facilities and other types of insanely
secure locations into luxury underground
apartments on their website you can
reserve a spot at one of their shelters
for just $55,000 per bunker or $35,000
per person in a group bunker plus
significant discounts Supply if you have
apocalypse skills so it's actually
pretty accessible you defin hear that
safety bang when the door
closes inside this
54,000 ft complex boasts everything you
could need to live through the end of
days okay let's get down and uh show you
what's underground
okay you're not in Kansas
anymore we're growing beneath Kansas
they have different Siz suits and other
facilities in common areas that make
life after the apocalypse more bearable
such as dining hall a chapel a bar movie
theaters pools game rooms and even
Gardens theater and loue
level so we have this uh media database
with about 3,000 movies on it anything
in particular you're interested in do
you have Armageddon oh we got everything
we got that all right let's roll that
all
right welcome to the paradise of the
be it's a saltwater pool is completely
computer controlled the pool is kept at
82° people do not expect to see a resort
pool in an underground bunker and we get
Dro Jaws every time people they go are
you kidding me it's basically a luxury
apartment building or a housing
community that has built to withstand a
nuclear blast moving up the tier are
companies like opum and resing S that
promis to build you the perfect bunker
underground conveniently right next to
your home their shelters are equip with
the little things then ensure that you
and your occupants will stay sane during
the apocalypse like fake sunlight
exposure and stylish wine vaults they
can customize these high-end buckers to
include anything you may want from
crypto mining rooms to basketball courts
and shooting ranges screens will even be
built into the apartment to show you
what's happening on the outside so you
can watch the suffering of the masses
from the safety and comfort of your own
bunker when the end times come these
types of extravagant shelters cost
anywhere from $4 million to $14 million
for other people that may sound like a
lot but for a millionaire like you that
is Chom change it's a small price to pay
for peace of mind we can never predict
or control what will happen in the world
but our first most powerful instinct is
always the same to protect the ones we
love to provide a sanctuary where they
can be safe and secure out of danger and
out of sight but with all the Comforts
of home and surrounded by their most
precious
possessions
opom creates underground Living Spaces
that are highly secure and completely
discreet yet beautifully appointed and
entirely
bespoke with everything you need to
relax and unwind and keep your mind and
body in Peak condition and even more
important than the luxuries these
shelters will also be equipped with
everything you need to stay alive for as
long as it taks on theg ground the
survival condo is spread across 15
floors and goes 200 ft up underground at
the top Under the Dome are the
recreation facilities like the pet Park
and climbing wall underneath that are
the mechanical level medical Bay and
food stores with luxury living quarters
spread across the next seven floors at
the bottom a further four floors house a
classroom a library a bar a gym and a
cinema a filtration system solar panels
and wind turbines for electricity and an
area for plant and animal farming that
will provide endless food down on the
store level there's an aquaculture setup
that can be used for raising fish and
hydroponics for growing organic
vegetables you can have salad daily with
this kind of setup oh yeah great it's
healthy yeah so we'll we'll have
tomatoes onions different kinds of
lettuces some kale uh blueberri
strawberries blackberries but even
without that there's still loads and I
mean loads of stockpiled food they're
designed to be impenetrable or at least
that's the pitch this is a converted
missile silo how much can this place
withstand it was engineered to withstand
a 10 kiloton nuclear warhead so Claire
those doors that we just came in through
weigh 8 tons each so they're 16,000 lb
they're uh armored steel filled with
concrete so you definitely hear that
safety bang when the door closes in
exchange for a massive chunk of money
these companies promis to build
something that will hopefully Poss
possibly maybe keep you alive when
everything hits the fan and the key word
here is
hope the thing about these bunkers is
while they do look nice and the idea of
them is nice we don't even know if they
will actually work when it comes down to
it in fact many experts agree that these
types of bunkers probably wouldn't work
in a real life scenario no matter how
much money you dump into them because in
a real Global disaster that destroys all
of society things go wrong and if these
billionaire bunkers don't perform
exactly like they're supposed to it's
all over all it would take is a little
contamination in their food growing room
or a tiny malfunction in their air
control room there's no room for even
the smallest error or you would be dead
like the rest of the world and come on
how much real world testing can you
really do with this stuff aside from
actually testing a nuke on it before you
sell it to a customer qu for one the
close ecosystems of underground
facilities are preposterously brittle
for example an indoor sealed hydroponic
garden is vulnerable to contamination
vertical fronts with moisture sensors
and computer controlled irrigation
systems look great in business plans and
on the rooftops of Bay Area startups
when a pallet of top soil or a row of
crops goes wrong it can simply be pulled
and replaced but the hermetically sealed
apocalypse grow room doesn't allow for
such doovers billionaires are being sold
a pipe dream of survival that the
designers of these luxury bunkers would
never be held accountable for which
makes selling Doomsday Bunkers a great
business think about it if your
customers actually have to use your
product and something goes wrong you
won't be around to deal with any of the
complaints or returns so if you've got
some real estate development experience
the billionaire bunker business may just
be the thing for you this business is
probably only going to keep growing man
you see this Mark Zuckerberg building
this $270 million bunker if you have a
billion dollars we have learned that you
can do whatever you want to do when Eli
M wants to send space things in space
you don't have to ask nobody's
permission Congress don't meet Senate
don't meet meet no Police Department got
to be warned he don't need a permit none
of that if you got a billion dollars you
do what you want to do and then you tell
them what you did and that's how it
[Music]
go